und damit sind wir auch schon quasi
nahtlos bei einer neuen folge von sehr
emotionale debatten die uns im
nachhinein betrachtet nirgendwohin
geführt haben die älteren werden sich
erinnern vor ungefähr einem jahr hat
ganz deutschland ziemlich aufgeregt über
hartz4 gestritten was gab es da nicht
für tolle vorschläge und hoffnung ja
leider die spd nur andrea nahles hinter
sich gelassen
und dann der deutsche wähler die spd
andere geschichte frage wenn man das
system hartz 4 schon nicht komplett
hinter sich lässt wofür sie argumente
gibt kann man es nicht wenigstens ein
bisschen menschlicher gestalten der
bundesrechnungshof nicht irgendwelche
linken spinner der bundesrechnungshof
gerade kritisiert dass wir
langzeitarbeitslose immer noch zwingen
an vollkommen sinnlosen maßnahmen
teilzunehmen
sie sollen kinder figuren ausschneiden
oder bilder ausmalen oder sie sollen
basteln und buntstifte und warengruppen
arbeiten jeder muss dann halt im mobil
wanderung
warum müssen erwachsene murmelbahn bauen
ist keine neue qualifikation bachelor of
mobile bahn oder das ist doch total
demütigend ja tatsächlich bekommt nur
noch jeder hundertste nur noch jeder
hundertste arbeitslose
langzeitarbeitslose eine sinnvolle
umschulung die auch nur in die nähe
eines jobs führen würde
trotzdem gibt der staat eine milliarde
im jahr für solche maßnahmen aus und
weil die ausgeschrieben werden kriegen
den zuschlag oft die ganz preiswerten in
hannover zum beispiel haben sie die
armen menschen ernsthaft mandalas malen
lassen das zuständige jobcenter hannover
verteidigt die mandalas als
therapeutische beschäftigung die in
jedem alter sehr entspannend wirkt und
spaß macht absolut macht spaß und
entspannt warum bieten sie keine
masturbation kursen entspannt auch
habe ich gehört so jetzt der witz jetzt
der witz wer mehr als sechs wochen in
seiner doodle maßnahme dabei war ist
dann für ein jahr ganz raus aus der
langzeitarbeitslosen statistik darum
geht es nämlich und natürlich macht man
auch den leuten vom vom jobcenter den
jobvermittlern druck die sollen die
kurse irgendwie voll kriegen egal wie
bescheuert ihr undercover-recherche
getarnt als tourist gelingt es ihm eine
lama tor für langzeitarbeitslose zu
begleiten wie damit bei der jobsuche
geholfen werden soll bleibt ein rätsel
ja das der niedrigste für die
arbeitslose wie lamas haben einen job
sogar unbefristet ja alles nur für den
doofe statistik danke dafür jetzt danke
der wirtschaftsstandort deutschland lebt
nicht nur von paketboten im niedriglohn
oder von den leuten die die rückkehr
liefert damit du fette qualle eine
miefige bude gar nicht mehr verlassen
muss nein die wahren helden sind
langzeitarbeitslose in sinnlosen
maßnahmen
sie geben alles um unsere
arbeitslosenquote zu senken wir sagen
danke danke dass ihr durch ihren
selbstlosen einsatz sätze wie diesen
ermöglicht halbiert deshalb fragt nicht
ob deutschland dieses natürlich ausmalt
mal dieses mandala für deutschland aus
das ist für mich
übrigens und jetzt wird weniger lustig
wenn man solche kurse verweigert weil
man sich beruflich gar nicht so in der
mandala branche sieht ja da gibt es
direkt sanktionen und das kann
buchstäblich jeden treffen sogar
alleinerziehende mütter wir haben noch
mal nachgeguckt allein im letzten jahr
nur im letzten jahr hat man 1200 allein
erziehenden hartz4 um 100 prozent
gekürzt 100% des 4
ja und das ist noch völlig egal was die
gemacht oder unterlassen haben man kann
nicht alles weg kürzen und die kinder
quasi mit bestrafen mediale aufschrei 0
dabei sind wir deutschen doch eigentlich
mitleid fähig wenn zum beispiel ist also
passiert für stuttgart 21 eine ganze
population mauereidechsen umgesiedelt
werden muss für 3,7 millionen da ist
offenbar genug mitleid dafür ist dass
der fehler von diesen allein erziehenden
die müssen statt baby mit einer
mauereidechse im jobcenter auflaufen
oder oder wenn der sachbearbeiter
richtig mittler kriegen soll dann kommen
wir natürlich mit einem traurigen
dieselfahrer ja das zieht immer aber
schön dass wir vor einem jahr mal
ausgiebig über hartz4 diskutiert und
geredet haben am 5 november urteilt das
verfassungsgericht ob sanktionen für
maßnahmen verweigerer so rechtens sind
falls nicht wird natürlich bitter für
eine ganze branche in der
selbstverständlich seriöse anbieter gibt
aber eben auch leute wie ralf kabelka
hallo
sie wissen nicht wohin mit ihren
langzeit arbeitslosen dann vertrauen sie
einen traditionsunternehmen willkommen
bei der statistik schönrechnerei kaberka
wir schönen statistiken seit drei
generationen schon mein opa heinrich hat
statistiken für hitler geschah schon
wieder drei kilometer autobahn fertig
sehr schön aber das wird den führer
freund
aus dem text ermitteln wir hier zunächst
die qualifikation der kunden
wo kommt das dreieck ein sehr gut und
wir bieten ein breit gefächertes angebot
an aufbaukursen die fit machen für den
arbeitsmarkt von morgen
seminare wie advanced raps brote
schmieren
denn wer brote schmieren kann wird
überall genommen diese achtsamkeit übung
nennen wir windows 10
hier war steht jetzt die
langzeitarbeitslosen mein auto hat jetzt
nicht unbedingt was mit ihm kurz zu tun
bei was dreckig
wenn sie diese hässlichen menschen nicht
mehr in ihre arbeitslosenstatistik sehen
wollen kein problem wir lassen sie
einfach für sie verschwinden nur bei uns
haben die kunden am ende der maßnahme
die chance sich als selbstständiger
unternehmer am markt durchzusetzen
[Musik]
euro damals bist du mich verarschen was
man auch ich kann auch ganz als jago von
statistik schönrechnerei kabelka absolut
skrupellos seit 19 uhr durch 34 mein
arzt hat mir verboten mich weiterhin so
aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt dass selbst ein bestechendes
ab
[Musik]